n michel platini était reçue donc
aujourd'hui à l'hôtel de ville de nancy
gérard et mika est une équipe de fr3
lorraine était présent je vous propose
d'écouter cet entretien à bâtons rompus
avec michel platini
michel bassi dit bonsoir merci nous
avons accordé cet entretien je sais que
vous êtes un petit peu fatigué avoue
vous n'êtes être fêté à nancy on va en
parler dans quelques instants je vais
savoir un petit peu de 48 heures en vue
de 48 heures après cette finale de
européenne qu'est ce qui reste dans
notre tête je fus le voleur qu'est ce
qu'elle a dans la tête de platine on se
rend pas contre je crois que quand on
fait quelque chose d'exceptionnel pour
ceux qui on l'a tellement on a tellement
eu peur pendant trois semaines que c'est
une sorte de délivrance pour pas dire
quelle joie profonde parce qu'on s'en
rend pas compte
la joie elle viendra petit à petit un
peu plus tard par les rescapés des
moments forts non des bonbons dont il
rêve d un moment fort je crois que le
deuxième but pour moi notamment très
très fort non mais oh la faute
et puis la joie dans le vestiaire après
entre nous lens est cette victoire
européenne vous y croyez vraiment est ce
que je nomme maintenant on peut venir
j'ai cours de la victoire mais quand
même c'était
on a tout fait pour essayer de l'avoir
c'est évident on n'était pas venus pour
participer à qu'elle ne pas l'aligner
et en plus sur notre sur nos terres où
c'est vraiment pas facile de gagner une
coupe d'europe
l'atv donc que sur l'ensemble de sur
l'ensemble de la compétition on était
les plus forts mais il fallait être plus
fort le match match décisif
là c'est pas évident qu'on les plans
contre qu'on était là on était les
meilleurs
par contre on à bénéficier du maximum de
réussite s initier aux réactions des
chances à la dernière rencontre
sinon sur l'ensemble je crois que sur un
an et un peu d'équipement ne
remplissions supérieure alors avec
maintenant un petit recul de quelques
heures pour juger cette coupe d'europe
techniquement mais écoutez j'ai eu beau
nier qu'il ya au téléphone on
aujourd'hui m'a dit que c'était super
mais il a vu une très très belle coupe
d'europe un très bon championnat
d'europe je veux dire et il a été juste
c'est ce qu'ils voyaient la télévision
en connaisseur et nous je pense que nous
dans notre cercle privé là on peut pas
se rendre compte ya un match qui vient
qu'il faut veiller le masque et patients
devaient donc eux aussi ont
techniquement c'était certainement très
valable plus fait de la chaleur du fait
des équipes qui étaient là ce n'est pas
les équipes
les chanteurs physiquement puis en fin
de saison vous savez on arrive à vous
physiquement et où hélas on est obligé
de jouer plutôt techniquement et
tactiquement ce qui rend le football
encore plus beau lors de l'intérieur
cette équipe de france à 12 ans au
gremio surpris quand même où la
connexion profonde elle m'a surpris dans
les moments difficiles parce que
je connais moi le football italien je
peux en parler on s'est un moment dans
les gouvernements difficile ils sont là
parce qu'elles veulent absolument gagner
et l'équipe de france dans les moments
difficiles m'a surpris peut-être qu'elle
a pris de la bouteille par rapport à
l'équipe 2 qui joue en espagne à séville
et l'alma je crois que des certains
joueurs qui moralement était très fort
et on peut pas je peux pas dire c'est le
sait un deux trois quatre joueurs quand
l'équipe de france et douze joueurs très
joueur même vingt joueurs dont 84 si la
grande année platini ce qui est déjà une
star du football d'aujourd'hui le
platier mischler store qu'est-ce que
qu'est ce que ça change pour vous je
n'ai rien je pense que avant je me
promenais dans si j'étais reconnu après
je me baladais en france j'ai quatre
coins du monde mais balade en europe ce
serait reconnu ça changera par sa chance
mais où je crois qu'on évolue pas ce
sont les gens qui sont autour de nous
qui évolueront peut-être le copain qui
me connaissaient quand l'état juif une
table qu'on puisse soit l'épaule
malheureusement mais vous savez je crois
qu'on aimait toujours tourner toujours
les mêmes on n'est pas des superstars
c'est tombé du balcon j'aurais quand
même le sentiment que technique au moins
de votre football de t'arriver peut-être
sommet de votre de l'autre à au sommet
de mon art je sais pas j'espère pas du
moins j'espère qu'a toujours une
progression à faire ce qu'il ya c'est
que on peut gagner des titres qu'ils
avaient de grandes équipes de clubs
comme la juventus en italie ou avec une
grande équipe de france ou avec une
grande équipe nationale comme l'équipe
de france parce que ce sont des grands
des petits ce faisant les grandes
équipes qui font les gros titres
donc moi je sais j'ai tout gagné parce
que j'avais des supers prêt qui est à
côté de moi alors vous avez tout gagné
justement mais après que ce que vous
avez envie de gagner même c'est quand on
gagne tout on peut casser la gueule
excusez moi et peut que tomber gm
essaiera de tenir de tenir ce ne sera
pas facile
or platini à 29 ans aujourd'hui il est à
l'injure ou encore pour deux ans pour d
après vous avez déjà à voir si je peux
dire aux états unis qu'on finirait pas
où on verra pas sûr
sept français je pense pas non non non
je crois que quand on est au paradis
faut pas le quitter c'est l'italie je
m'excuse mais c'est comme ça pour un
footballeur c'est la balle c'est la base
qui a de plus beau d'ailleurs voyez le
meilleur job et la métallerie et après
un bon bain j'essaierai de voir un autre
système de vie parce que tout le monde
rêve d'aller un jour aux états unis moi
si je peux y aller en tant que
footballeur n'ayant certaines portes
ouvertes c'est c'est plus intéressant
serait bête de ne pas en profiter
alors aujourd'hui non si vous fêtez
jeunes gens vous remettons la colle à
koufa dit c'est un lorrain qui remet la
coupe alors un set lorenzi revenu
d'abord vous avez le don du revenu moi
je reviens de temps en temps je reviens
à nancy où je vais je vais dans les
vosges
mon sinon un chef j'essaierai d'y aller
c'est sûrement la fin du mois mais
discrètement parce que j'ai j'ai encore
ma grand mère j'ai toute ma famille
c'est salue comme lui font tout le monde
vous fait tout mon émission et
j'essaierai d'aller voir ça fait très
longtemps que je suis partant d'un
régiment de virton je me suis j'ai un
petit peu le football français bien sûr
et football laurent blanc c'est du
mauvais montage et le suivi le football
l'orage de football l'ancien je suis à
travers mon père et je suis aussi le
football médecin qui a gagné brillamment
la coupe la coupe de france alors
maintenant qu'est-ce qu'est ce qui vous
attend des vacances longues vacances de
savez j'avais retourner le 1er août en
italie où on vous demandez encore de
gagner toujours de gagner de gagner le
championnat d'italie de gagner
éventuellement la coupe des clubs
champions
donc pendant un mois je les cite pas
penser au football et je vais me reposer
surtout surtout dans la tête parce que
c'est très difficile nous a le sentiment
que cette victoire en coupe d'europe ou
encore mettre plus de pression pour
reprendre une célèbre expression de
plus de pression sur vous ou encore en
italie c'est la pression de l'asub je
sais pas en fait vous savez du moment
qu'on donne tout ce que l'on peut si on
gagne pas c'est pas un problème
c'est vraiment pas un problème je crois
qu'il faut être sportif est toujours un
gagnant est toujours un perdant la
pression qui sait revenir il faut
justement sans levée de cette pression
sans levée de ce stress et je crois que
ce qui arrivait à l'équipe de france des
sondés ce stress grâce peut-être des
joueurs qui sont un peu plus
expérimentés surtout une chez dargaud
qui nous faisait faites vous plaisir
donner le maximum de vous même si vous
semblez contre meilleurs campings c'est
la loi du sport dont précisément où
parler de michel hidalgo c'est aussi une
belle histoire d'amour entre lui une
équipe de france puis entre lui et vous
aussi
on a commencé ensemble ils finir avec
des gens plutôt coin mais vous savez
c'est très difficile de dire bon michel
hidalgo parce qu'il aurait michel qui va
venir c'est c'est pas évident de parler
comme cela
non les caméras michel hidalgo est une
personne que je connais très bien qui
est très sensible très honnête très
tolérante en rimes chez une personne
avec qui j'ai eu des problèmes quand je
jouais avec nancy contre n'en pense
qu'on se frictionnaient tout le temps et
ensuite j'ai beaucoup apprécié c'est une
personne qui a beaucoup plus de
caractère et qui qui va consolider
certainement le groupe et qui a d'autres
qualités que michel hidalgo dans ce
groupe aussi second il a encore un bel
avenir devant lui on dit parfois que
certains joueurs soient un petit peu
c'est pas tout jeune ouais ouais c'est
vrai ses possessions 29 ans pour un coût
beurre pour un footballeur mais sa
dépendance france et pas très jeune et
alice à ces jeunes parce qu'il joue un
peu plus tard ils s'épargnent plus plus
dans l'année disons que vous savez
les joueurs il y en a des très bons vous
pourriez que les juniors ont été
champions d'europe se sont qualifiées
pour les jeux olympiques les les espoirs
ont été encore de finale comme disait
monsieur qui n'y avait à l'époque été
déjouée indispensable y en a pas une
équipe arsenal qui arrive le type de
francs sera bonne quand on repartira
était bon en avant qu'on dise quoi et
les ah non si c'est la même chose j'ai
vu que tu sais exactement la même chose
où tout passe le pays n'est pas
indispensable
je pense pas non non on va pas rester
sur une possible accord
non c'est la joie c'est la joie chez
nancy j'ai été fêté par des amis bien
sûr aujourd'hui je pense qu'elle n'a
plus que d'habitude parce qu'on a gagné
mais ça me fait vraiment plaisir d'être
à nancy c'est la seule manifestation je
faisais parce que nancy c'est une partie
de mon coeur je veux vous remercier vous
en prie